la ville de Blois a vendu l'Hôtel Dieu
pour 3200000 € à une société immobilière
spécialisée dans le patrimoine elle
compte y aménager 97 appartements promis
à la vente deux musées verront également
le jour dans l'édifice le projet
d'aménagement l'association des Amis de
l'Hôtel Dieu le suit de très près opposé
depuis le départ à la vente de l'édifice
ses membres ont engagé un éè recours
cette fois pour contester le permis de
construire on aurait pu déjà garder une
partie plus importante du bâtiment au
blaois accessible au public puisque
c'est quand même une partie de
l'histoire de la ville à l'époque les
gens venaient à l'hôpital ici il y avait
les la plupart des Blaisois ont vu le
jour dans la maternité de l'hôpital et
ils sont
attachés à ce bâtiment la réhabilitation
prévoit de maintenir le parking existant
aux grand â des
opposants inst
une centaine de parking en copropriété
privé alors qu'il n'existe pas à Blois
la possibilité d'avoir enfin un grand
parc public dans la ville basse de la
ville il y a un règlement d'urbanisme
qui impose en terme de logement comme en
terme d'activité un nombre de places
soit au logement soit à la surface et
donc on a dû répondre le minimum on
aurait préféré ne pas faire de
stationnement mais le règlement impose
le nombre de stationnement
la société immobilière a chiffré la
rénovation et l'aménagement à 25
millions d'euros des travaux qui vont
devoir attendre l'instruction du recours
par le tribunal
administratif on s'inquiète pour le
bâtiment qui est vide c'est et
l'augmentation des coups travaux et la
dégradation supplémentaire et
l'inquiétude d'un bâtiment vide non
chauffé et sans usage seule certitude la
mise en route des fouilles
archéologiques préalables à tout
chantier il est prévu qu'elle débute en
janvier 2024